hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
today we're going to be looking at
several different
vocab words that have to do with viruses
um or other infectious agents so virus
virus viroid
10 more so let's go ahead and get
started
but before we do i want you to know that
you can get free study notes by using
the url in the description below so that
will be a free pdf of the entire
finished board with all of the
notes written on it
so let's go ahead and get started
first of all i'm going to talk to you
about several infectious agents that's
going to be virus virion some of these
subviral agents prions and bacteria ages
now all of these infectious agents that
we are talking about today
um i think we need a
you there actually infectious agents
these are all
a cellular
okay a cellular meaning
not composed of cells certainly there
are infectious agents that are cellular
bacteria
um helminthic worms fungal pathogens
protozoan pathogens and so on
but here we're just talking about
infectious agents that are a cellular so
not composed of cells simpler than cells
let's get started with the most obvious
one the one that most students know and
that is a virus now the virus consists
of a protein coat and that protein coat
is called
a capsid it's made up of like protein
something that's called capsule mirrors
and that protein code or capsid
surrounds a core of nucleic acid the
nucleic acid can be dna
or
rna
and that just depends on the specific
type of viruses some viruses use dna
some viruses use rna um to carry their
genetic material
so the virus is something that can
replicate itself so capable of
self-replication as long as it's
infecting a host cell so it's an
obligate intracellular parasite that
means it must infect the host cell to be
able to replicate and cause the disease
that it causes
and then these viruses may or may not
have an envelope
um now i have a much more in-depth video
called introduction to viruses that goes
into viruses their different shapes and
their different structures and their
replication cycles so you can check out
that video introduction to viruses if
you want to learn more about viruses but
now let's go on to some of these other
similar vocab words we've got virion
okay virion
this is the infective form of a virus
specifically the infected form of a
virus that is outside
of a host cell so it's outside of a host
cell and it has the capacity to infect
a host cell that's a virion so if you're
looking at virus replication cycles um
one of the the last step of that cycle
is usually release that's the release of
all of those offspring or progeny
virions
outside of the host cell so they can
kind of float away and infect another
cell so that infected form of the virus
outside a host that has the capacity to
infect a host cell that's the very own
now we're going to talk about three
different subviral
agents now subviral agents these are
infectious agents that are
smaller
smaller than viruses with only
some
of their properties
so as we go through these three
different subviral agents
you're going to see that this this is
consistently true they're going to be
missing things that are found in viruses
and having some properties of virus but
missing other properties so let's start
off with viroids okay
vibroids
are known for infecting
plants
so this is an infectious plant pathogen
it's made of self replicating so it can
replicate itself as long as it's inside
a host cell
circular
rna so these are always circular
organics
this is without
a protein coat okay so they don't have
that protein coat that capsid that a
full virus is always going to have this
is literally just
circular rna that can self-replicate if
it gets into a plant cell
or a specific plant cell right whatever
type of plant it infects it also does
not code directly for proteins viruses
are
going to code for the proteins you know
both proteins that make up the code but
also sometimes their own enzymes and
that's going to be missing from virus
and there are lots of different kinds of
vitamins if you go google viral you'll
get a whole long list of examples of
different plant pathogens that fall into
this category
now let's talk about the second type of
subviral agent and that is virusoid so a
virusoid again is an infectious
plant pathogen like all known viroids
and virusoids are plant pathogens
this is different from a viroid though
because it's made of
non-self-replicating
genetic material so while a vibrant or
sorry a viroid is like a virus and that
they're self-replicating a virus soy can
not replicate itself even if it gets
into a host cell
it can't replicate itself
it can be made up of circular
or
this is another kind of difference from
a thyroid or linear rna
so a virusoid can be made up of circular
or linear rna the vibrate was only
circular rna
still without a protein coke
but what makes the virus able to
replicate since it cannot self-replicate
it has to infect
a cell
at the same time that's this
co-infection
with a specific what we call helper
virus
so only if the virus gets into the host
cell
where
another virus
can is already replicating to serve as a
helper only then can it replicate
because that helper virus is going to
have the machinery through which this
one will be able to replicate not by
itself but with the help of the helper
virus
now let's talk about the third type of
subviral agent that's the satellite
virus
similar to a virus
but actually encoding one or more of
their own enzymes
so viruses again the viral dna or rna
whichever one it's using is going to
encode
for
its sort of its own proteins and some of
its own enzymes and the satellite virus
is similar but it's still
non-self-replicating the satellite virus
still requires co-infection with the
helper virus
one example
of a human pathogen that is a satellite
virus is hepatitis d
now i have seen textbooks particularly
older textbooks that will actually
classify hepatitis d as a virusoid in
fact the major microbiology textbook
that i use in my class used to
characterize hepatitis d as a virus but
now it has been split out into this
related
uh
category of a satellite virus because it
does encode like one of its own enzymes
so hepatitis d again it still needs
co-infection with a helper virus that's
usually going to be hepatitis b
so that they can can replicate and that
is a human virus
let's go on to two more infectious
agents let's start with prions prions
are misfolded
proteins
[Music]
and this really kind of rocked the
scientific world when this was
discovered for quite a while scientists
believe that prion diseases were caused
by just some kind of virus they hadn't
found yet and the scientists who
ultimately
you know was able to show
that it's just a misfolded protein and
not like a full virus um that was a big
shift in the scientific knowledge around
these diseases pre-owned diseases
include things like cruciferous disease
um
bovine spongiform encephalopathy which
is the kind of fancy name for mad cow
disease uh my other appearance is kuru
if you want to learn more about creons i
do have a full length video on prions
that you can check out
but pre-odds they do cause progressive
disease and humans progressive meaning
getting worse with time and currently as
of the filming of this video there is no
cure
for any prion disease and so if you
contract one and it will ultimately be
legal
and then the final infectious agent
we're talking about is a bacteriophage
this is also called
a phage so bacteriophage or phage you
can call it either one this is simply a
virus that infects bacteria now i have a
video called transduction which is a
form of horizontal gene transfer and
bacteria that uses bacteriophages
and in that video transduction i'll talk
more about bacteriophages what they look
like how they replicate and so make sure
you check that one out
now we're going to go into some sort of
similar related vocab
this these are words that don't refer
directly to an infectious agent
but that are related in some way so
let's go ahead and get started the first
two pro phage and pro virus these are
very similar a prophage is when you have
a phage genome remember it's a
bacteriophage a phage genome that has
integrated
into the host genome and you'll see that
depicted in my transduction video but
that's where you've got a phage it's a
genome gets like injected into the
bacteria cell that it's infecting and
then actually integrated or incorporated
into the bacterial chromosome pro virus
is very similar except instead of being
a phage in fact infecting a bacterium
this is an animal virus that's infecting
an animal cell so an animal virus genome
that again has integrated
or incorporated into the host genome we
call that a pro virus um hiv will form a
pro virus when it infects human cells
it's dna connection or it's a
genetic material which is actually rna
gets reversed transcribed into
dna and then that gets incorporated or
integrated into the host's genome
um
now let's talk about virulence virulence
is the degree
to which one of these infectious agents
is pathogenic basically how
you know how severe it is so we would
say that you know a strain with higher
virulence is more pathogenic causing
more severe disease a strain with lower
virulence or you know a less virulent
strain would be something that's less
pathogenic that if it causes some kind
of symptoms of disease they would be
more mild if they were from a less
virulent strain
virulence factor is a product something
that the pathogen makes
that assists in its ability to cause
disease
for
example some pathogens will
make certain enzymes that help them to
cause
more disease so i have videos on the
coagulase test and the catalase test
which is ways that you can determine in
a laboratory if a particular bacterium
produces coagulase or produces catalase
both of these are enzymes that assist in
their in a pathogen's ability to cause
disease and so they would both be
virulent factors coagulase and catalase
so you can check those out if you want
to learn more about those
viremia you know anytime we see emia at
the end of a word this is the presence
of virus in the bloodstream
so in the blood
if you have if a patient has viremia
like an infection in their bloodstream
that's a very very dangerous situation
you never want to have
large amounts of virus in the blood
now let's talk about the virus side a
virus is a chemical
or a physical
treatment
that destroys or inactivates the virus
so maybe you've heard of something being
a bacteria side or a fungicide
or something being bacteria cyto or
fungicidal that means that
that it's some kind of treatment that
would destroy the bacterium or the
fungus
and a virus side is basically the
equivalent for a virus some kind of
medication or chemical that is virus
that means it would inactivate or kill
the virus
and now we're getting down to that very
last one viral titer viral tiger is the
number of virions remember virion is
talking about the infected the infective
form of a virus outside of her cell that
has the capacity to infect the cell the
viral tighter is the number of virions
per some unit of volume
and most commonly i think you see
milliliter so for example
um
you know 100 virions per milliliter of
blood that's an example of a viral tire
a higher viral tighter means a higher
viral load in that um in that organism a
lower viral tighter would be a you know
fewer viruses per unit of volume so
that's the end today make sure that you
subscribe make sure you hit that bell
icon for notifications make sure you
check out some of these other videos to
keep learning i wish you all the best in
your studies make sure you grab that
link in the description below so you can
get all those free study notes and thank
you for watching biology professor see
you next time